donc enfin bon c'était quitté hier avec
une première journée palpitante avec des
parties assez extraordinaires et on
espère que ça continue sur le même
rythme exactement avec du suspense dans
tous les matchs donc voilà tout est
encore possible aujourd'hui donc on ne
sait pas on verra quoi on va regarder un
peu comment cette équité hier le match
sor André Keane ce qui a déjà fait un
petit écart il mène trois un et il peut
entrer de jeu Fabien peut-être faire un
écart quasiment décisif enfin trois
points de retard en trois parties ce
serait trop pour André Kim probablement
envoyer un peu tête un petit décalage en
fait ouais c'est la partie du cargo qui
qui débute en
partie en partie principale on aurait
peut-être dû suivre icaru Fabien bon on
peut aller voir
tu as besoin que d'une petite nul pour
pour assurer la calife on a décidé de
pas suivre mais le suspense quand même
entier dans ce match on a on a vu des
remontada déjà je me rappelle tu sais je
crois que c'était un Montpellier ou
Marseille était mené 4-0 à la mi-temps
exactement
possibilité il y avait aussi un match de
tennis je crois un mec qui était mené
6-0 5-0300 et avait réussi à remonter
c'est tout est toujours possible Fabien
complètement complètement d'ailleurs ils
font bien d'ailleurs de montrer que
cette partie de pas démarrer les autres
comme ça on sera bien sûr on verra et
imagine que Luda gagne faut-il qu'on
cesse d'autres matchs et pas attendre
18h pour la seconde ronde peut-être la
troisième la quatrième et commencer
peut-être ensuite à 21h la suite des
autres rencontres enfin peut-être être
intéressant aussi c'est
[Rires]
Pogba et le marabout quoi bah oui ça
part ça part et c'est ceux qui a les
blancs bon c'est une grande solide
[Musique]
pas forcément le pion et si tu le prends
mais il y a toujours des compensations
mais après j'ai vu une que saut il va te
faire un truc pas trop violent il va pas
passer son temps à manger des pions et
être sous développer il va probablement
qu'il avait un peu jouer avec les Noirs
ouais ouais alors
[Musique]
je sais plus tard mais je crois qu'on
avait vu un poste
incroyable
donc ouais
mais
a priori oui donc c'est un centre de jeu
pour les Noirs voilà je me rappelle cet
épisode a absolument rien
on avait regardé on était mort de rire
mais
qu'est-ce que je veux mais je crois que
en fait effectivement c'est plutôt une
bonne manière de parler
ça relance tout de suite
pourquoi pas parce que c'est grand rock
l'idée ou simplement une tour en V8 on
va voir
un logiquement tu as envie de faire
fouger 5 et cavaliers 5 non
l'ordi n'est pas du tout content et ne
prospe pas Échec
cavalier G4 peut-être
bien bien se passer
le problème de fou j'ai 5
il fait 3 ouais ça a l'air dans ce match
aussi de vite de vite se décanter parce
que là
il est mal développé mais il fait ce
qu'il peut il a sorti son foot case noir
avant de l'emmer il veut sortir le foie
fin il veut ok enfin il fait que des
trucs normaux bah c'est vrai que s'il y
a pas
une petite tactique un petit truc rapide
avec les Noirs bah un moment tu auras
juste un peu moins pour pas grand chose
mais là bon tu as encore mieux développé
on va voir
mais pas trouvé quelque chose dans les
quoi venir ça se passe pas trop mal pour
le moment pour pour Wesley ce match
après voilà ce qui est dommage pour
Android
que je sais pas à quel point c'est bon
pas bon quoi mais c'est dommage qu'il
soit pas plus au courant en fait imagine
tu joues ça tu connais bien ça peut être
dangereux je veux dire si tu joues les
coups que tu as tout analysé avec l'ordi
tu es bien quoi
si tu joues humainement tu as juste un
pion de moi t'as pas de raison d'arriver
à forcément à outiller après d'un autre
côté André Kin c'est à dire qu'il a quoi
ici match perdu en vrai
ce que tu as un accueil il a dit j'ai vu
un interview qu'il était content qu'il y
avait réussi à caler deux trois petites
prépa donc j'imagine qu'il parlait
surtout de la partie 1 ou la vite mis
dans danger dans la pétrole oui
complètement et puis même dans sa
berlinoise ça c'est intéressant là ce
sont son truc enfin intéressant ou pas
d'ailleurs mais il avait un peu moins là
puis
reposer les gagner très vite donc je
suppose que les joueurs enfin il y a
quand même plus d'argent pour les
championnats du monde enfin c'est il y a
plus d'argent qu'au candidat aussi mise
à part pas la première place donc faut
dire que les joueurs peuvent vraiment
sortir des prépas là c'est un des
tournois les c'est peut-être même le
tournoi le mieux doté de l'année parce
qu'il y a plus d'argent que dans les
grandes chaises tours aussi
toujours plus que les candidats
donc
partant de là c'est pas étonnant en
quelque sorte que les joueurs soient
bien préparés ouais ben écoute on va
voir tout est possible de toute façon
c'est un pion de plus et c'est un gros
avantage au blanc
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que tu veux faire donc
j'ai cinq fougères
bon on voit la jauge hein que ça marche
pas du tout là il y a pas trop à hésiter
juste tu regardes la jauge et que tu as
l'évaluation mais les coups ça doit
juste être plus en prendre à me prendre
enfin et tout enfin il y a rien en fait
sur G4 il veut d'un F4 je pense
et faire la finale qui est complètement
nul mais quel génie c'est magnifique en
fait oui
il veut juste nul Wesley déjà faut voir
jauge malheureusement non mais ce serait
une sacrée aide et là il veut d'un F4
c'est sûr qu'est-ce qu'il est pleutre
quand même
on peut rappeler qu'est-ce que les
enjeux du tournoi oui on peut te le
rappeler bah c'est il y a c'est le
tournoi le mieux doté de l'année je
crois celui-là le plus d'argent donc
voilà l'enjeu l'argent donc tous ces
jours là sont qualifiés par internet et
maintenant ça joue en réel et on a ce
qui était pas les hier quelques quelques
aficionados experts du jeu sur Internet
comme Raja BOV Sarine André Kin un petit
peu saut aussi
qui sont vraiment des experts du jeu
internet
Hikaru aussi bien évidemment
et de joueurs qu'on voit plus
ponctuellement
comme guérisse séviant qui n'était pas
qualifié qui a été repêché
mais oui parce que les vannes n'a pas pu
venir jouer et dans les joueurs vraiment
forts qui sont faits éliminer il y a un
éponyashi qui se fait sortir un
paragraphe comme je le disais il faut
bien chic très en forme mais bon voilà
contre un spécialiste il a il a un petit
peu souffert et Ding aussi dingly Rennes
donc les lumineux les deux finalistes
champion du monde et éliminés par Niall
Sarine lui aussi qui s'est vraiment le
jeune Indien spécialisé sur sur les
joutes internet dernièrement un peu
comme praganda ces jeunes Indiens qui
sont vraiment très fun sur Internet
tours
bon ça change ça change il y a que les
carreaux qui a réussi à faire là
vraiment la transition c'est le sol et
Magnus et cahier des six il attaque B7
il menace qui a essayé 8 qui est prend à
7 attention
quand il a plus aucun risque de perdre
si tu lui fais un petit cadeau il va
aller la chercher
voilà je pense qu'il va la gagner ouais
ça va faire trois points d'écart qui a
été 6
maintenant ça va être signe quoi
aussi tour des 6 3 F5 et
ça sert à rien
classique pour défendre et attaquer
c'est pas trop mieux entre les pions
[Musique]
ça me va bon ben si plus c'est plus mais
a priori
des fois c'est hallucinant
les Douda qui a gagné
la stratégie en marche
ouais et il y a une victoire de guéri
ouais bah vu la solidité des deux
ça va être quoiirido mais ça c'est
incroyable quand il est le truc quand
même
[Musique]
mais après ça a gagné facile non
deux il est très heureux quoi bah si il
fait ça c'est
je pense pas tu mets ta tour en des deux
je sais maxime a dit qu'il était très
stressé généralement
moi récemment mais
je me souviens quand il était un
Gibraltar qui avait justement le truc
pour les battements de cœur il battait
du coeur comme un fouet
et puis tu pousses enfin c'est hyper
facile et il avait même il saigné du nez
des fois quand on est parti
bon là il va pouvoir le gérer plus
tranquillement de toute façon si tu te
fais prendre la tour des trois et puis
elle froide
un peu d'avance quoi
et on va aller voir séviant ah c'est
bien l'air pas mal
des cinq peut-être c'est pas le coup à
jouer donc c'est Vian il a les blancs
qui pourrait piquer quasiment le match
là je pense c'est le match qu'on suivra
ça va être le moins les trois autres en
fait ils sont quasi pliés en réalité
dans tous les cas il s'est peut-être
celui où il y a le plus de chance que ça
tourne quoi il est peut-être pas bien en
fait c'est bien
[Musique]
c'est que si la soif on sait ce qui boit
de quoi de l'avion bah ouais je pense
la barre n'est pas contente
j'avais vu en fait roi des deux dame
mais c'est marrant parce que je lui ai
pas dit mais j'allais dire faire gaffe
de pas faire [ __ ] de parce que ça perd
en ligne oui bah c'est la ligne en fait
ce qu'il y a de con c'est que fallait
sauter sur l'échange de dames quoi enfin
c'était clair quoi tu peux pas juste
jouer une position compliquée comme ça
surtout quand tu mets le score avec là
tu te voilà
c'est pas que
l'idée c'est que sur des 5 il veut faire
eux prend des c'est prendre des fou B5
échec fou des 7 échanger
petit rock et ça a l'air de rien mais tu
vas faire B3 ou B2 genre full 7 on va
dire bloquer la colonne B3 rock B2
et tu te dis que tu es un peu meilleur
structure c'est vrai tu as deux îlots
contre 3 tu peux potentiellement
peut-être faire un petit C4 avant et
c'est d'échanger ses comptes et des
pions isolés en face
tu as un fou pas mal placé sur la
diagonale voilà donc c'est pas grand
chose mais c'est pas rien non plus
donc il a joué
5 en fait je connais pas mais c'est une
autre manière de jouer il a fait qu'il y
avait trois attaque le fou et a priori
la turbinette n'aime pas trop parce
qu'il dit qu'il y avait des pro-4 mais
si tu connais pas fauxerre parce que tu
te mets un peu avec les pièces en l'air
à droite à gauche et puis même s'il y a
rien de trop tactique rien prend C5 pour
prendre la paire de fou et jouer
absurde moi mais bon c'est un peu ouvert
je sais pas ce que ça va enfin je dois
pas être super dangereux pour le noir
mais c'est pas c'est pas anodin non plus
comme position enfin si tu connais bien
que les blancs il a l'air parce qu'il
joue tempo ça fait un peu peur donc
d'ailleurs il a pas pris
le 5 maintenant d'accord ouais mais
c'est pas une bonne nouvelle le jeu
contre quelqu'un qui connaît très bien
il est un peu en danger là
quelque chose comme ça ouais ça
ressemble à une nièce mais si spécifique
de l'autre côté mais là il prend la
caisse du cavalier et puis tu as deux
fous de fou qui font rien donc je sais
pas vrai ça peut mal se passer pour pour
les Noirs attraper dans l'ouverture un
petit peu là on va voir s'il a la
solution du problème ou pas mais c'est
pas évident
[Musique]
qu'on a une bonne version de la mienne
à 6 et puis bon ben après on va voir ok
mais il connaît par cœur en fait ça
donne du fu G5 et aussi ça permet de
tourage 3 peut-être pour rentrer en jeu
le long de la troisième rangée donc en
tout cas fougère c'est ce qu'il a envie
de faire au prochain coup dangereux
c'était quoi 16 ouais
un peu sur les fêtes surprise et que ce
soit encore un territoire un peu un peu
inexploré mais
ouais mauvaise nouvelle ça va pas durer
c'est dommage parce que ça donne des
positions intéressantes en plus à jouer
c'est un peu différent des e4-5
habituelles là c'est peut-être toi je
crois tour G3 déjà
ou tu auras trois fois pour échanger
revenir avec la tour en E3
après tu peux jouer avec des G3 fougères
ouais bah c'est le H4 l'eau de manière
de la musique sur C4 c'est ça ouais
c'est ça et en fait l'idée sur H6 c'est
que tu dis oui mais ça a servi quasiment
rien mais en fait ça te sert à sortir ta
tour vers E3 donc là tu peux caler avec
vous trois tu remets ta torrent E3 et
après tu as le choix avec ton roi en
fait elle est hyper bien placé cette
tour en trois il veut taper sur le Kibe
3 c'est bien joué mais du coup tu auras
je crois c'est vraiment enfin c'est
vraiment un coup multifonction j'avais
pas vu mais tu protèges aussi
après là tu te mets un peu on vis-à-vis
du fossé vite oui mais bon tu vas te
décaler en G3 tu te mettras en physique
parce que le truc en fait c'est que sur
genre tu rage 3 D6 tours G3 admettons il
y a pas d'arme Pro 5 enfin il y a
peut-être Marc on a pas trop encore à
cause de ce bizarre d'habitude il est de
l'autre côté quand même
[Musique]
juste tu prends un F2 et il prend B3
mais tu as trop d'activités je serais
bien assise si je pouvais genre
D4 enfin je sais pas j'ai pas le coup
que j'ai envie de faire [ __ ] de base
mais ce qui est assis c'est tellement
moche j'aurais pas envie de le voir
revenir en C5 me casser les pieds quoi
après toi aussi dame 4 fous des trois
très rapide pour aller taper le rock sur
petit
en fait on s'en fout
j'y crois pas en fait j'ai l'impression
que c'est complètement foutu pour les
Noirs déjà mais bon la jauge donne égal
je réfléchirais déjà un coup comme
cavalier C5 avec les Noirs perso je
regardais juste un carreau qui va
réussir à faire nul évidemment
donc on prend des 6 ouais bon bah écoute
on rentre dans une phase de jeu
différent on dira pas d'attaque trop
contre les rois parce qu'il y a des
dames échangées mais meilleure structure
pour les blancs et puis tu fais un petit
tour ensuite tu es pas trop bien mais tu
gigotes quoi
au lieu de gigoter tu essayes carrément
d'avoir un vrai avantage et qu'il y a 5
attaque c'est si s'attaque des 6 c'est
pas mal il est il met la pression avec
les blancs en tout cas et il car vous ça
doit ça doit être quasi fait
on rigole depuis tout à l'heure mais en
fait il est pas bien
non voilà en fait
il va créer un pion passé t'attaque un
peu tellement bien fait pour lui qui
perdent non mais bon il va pas perdre
les quatre en fait non mais pour
doudouard ce serait très bien fait pour
lui qui perdent trois et demi à 4h30 et
qui paye son son
oui oui non mais c'est assez grave
ça ferait déjà trois trois enfin le
match il est pas si alors après ça
change tu joues pas pareil
si c'est possible j'en sais rien
peut-être parce que là bon tu fais quand
même bloqué puis 5 secondes tu vas pas
arriver mais oui en tout cas clairement
tu as même ton club tu aurais fait nul
déjà une partie normale de perdre comme
ça de jeter à la poubelle la partie
donc là on regarde si tu fais du là tu
as pas perdu en fait
dégoûté de cette arnaquer comme il s'est
fait arnaquer mais bon après oui mais
c'est ça
je sais pas le chemin du monde de blés
[Musique]
j'imagine que dans le tournoi ce qui
aime faire arnaquer une fois deux
pendant le Pen enfin pendant il a pas
jeté à la poubelle un bon club après à
pas jouer
non bah en plus ce que je veux dire
c'est vraiment dommage parce que si tu
as envie de jouer un truc un peu
exotique et te refaire plaisir parce que
tu as mais je sais pas on va même un
combi roi une vie noire un grand bidule
centre
un truc un peu ok c'est pas grave enfin
donc là c'est bien il a gagné donc ça
maintient un peu de suspense mais
là en fait c'est juste cracher sur les
échecs
en plus c'est bien fait pour lui quand
même
la première tu vois il la perd il était
bien c'était la Catalane là qu'on avait
vu en direct
il s'est pris des barbelés des barbelés
avant ils sont mêlés dedans il s'est
griffé merde mais voilà
par contre l'autre
qui revient à 3,5
lui a sauvé des trucs encore pire que ça
notamment celle où il avait un kéoline
moi et c'était fini notre cahier qu'on
tourne
donc on va voir on va voir si
c'est bien arrive à s'accrocher pareil
mais le réalisme important quand tu es
bien dans ces matchs c'est important de
scorer Pinter il sent espace
et le fou il va repartir un jour
c'est 3 il ressort par la main c'est
deux rois B3 tours F2
[Musique]
donc on joue sur
il est là pour 2000 cavalieres donc ok
donc il a sauvé son fou
ou non là est jolie ouais
à part jouer quel conseil me donner pour
progresser avec le site à résoudre les
problèmes bah oui oui ça c'est très bon
choix faire les leçons
tu as des très bons livres aussi
gagner aux échecs comment progresser aux
échecs aussi bon une fois que tu gagnes
déjà pourquoi progresser mais bon par
plaisir on va dire mais sur le site web
tout ce qui est problème c'est nickel
parce que ça va augmenter ta vision ton
ta puissance de calcul tu as un meilleur
ressenti et des combinaisons possibles
et puis
et puis et puis bah ouais jouer
m'étonnes un peu tu fais pas que je veux
pour jouer essaye de revoir les parties
pas refaire les mêmes erreurs etc il va
y avoir tout revu trois H7 G4 fou G6 H5
je me dis que
[Musique]
G4 tourner devant
un moment donné mais bon oui le truc
c'est que ouais même là il se prend pas
la tête tu prends tu prends F5 et tu
prends F7 il y a toujours le plot
raciste
dès le début une très bonne partie
d'ailleurs pour pour illustrer le
problème
c'est une super illustration
de plus bientôt 3 abandon et Sarine qui
prend les devants ok oui on est de
retour les amis alors ouais on s'est un
peu fait avoir par les horaires désolé
ça parce que ça devait reprendre à 10 et
ça reprit à 4 donc on s'est un peu ouais
un peu dépassé mon Fab donc on commence
par suivre un peu
IKO
avoir envie de fermer le match là
maintenant bah oui oui
entendre mon complet quoi après il
aurait pu faire un banc Claude être un
peu sport ouais beau joueur
elle est censée être solide après on va
voir comment Douda s'en sort
après peut-être je me dis peut-être
qu'il avait mis ce clic le 3 qui voulait
faire 4 et qu'après ça
je me demande ouais mais au pire
il va prendre puis on prend entre une
Française vendent des changes ou tu fais
C4 tu joues une sorte d'anglaise tu fais
B3 bah tu fais un B3 et puis je sais pas
va te démerder de jouer quoi c'est pas
grave enfin c'est pas grave
mais en fait c'est pas mauvais coup non
bah c'est mieux que G4
ça me met déjà été joué en partie longue
sérieuse pas une partie carriac un an de
caryaki ou un truc comme ça car
équilinande c'est possible
il y a un million en jeu pour le coup
après de toute façon c'est con enfin
quand même tu as fait E3 tu as fait cinq
fois
pourquoi tu joues en fait
ah la jauge c'est excitée après F5
c'est rarement un bon coup de toute
façon ça c'est un commandement n'a pas
touché à ce pion si possible
ko qui
a fait pousser deux qui est pas validé
par la jauge sûrement que c'était qui
est D4 en fait le bon coup non ouais
tout simplement
ok c'est logique j'ai 5 qui veut G4 et
il faut prendre
[Musique]
en Fab c'est chaud c'est très chaud
complètement tu peux pas faire genre un
truc genre G4 qui est 4 fois H2O H1 F4
touche le fou puis F3 tu vas peut-être
te faire bloquer par G3 ouais c'est
compliqué très dur à calculer c'est
compliqué mais il part pour
intuitivement c'est ce que j'aurais fait
après c'est dur d'avoir le résultat
entre guillemets de la ligne mais c'est
vrai que hors troll faire ses deux fois
quatre parties c'est pas mal mais c'est
mieux de le faire en deux sets en fait
du coup de faire cette un premier jour
et cette deuxième jour que de tout lié
enfin c'est du coup
et ça jouerait un départage
mais c'est tellement plus logique en
fait je trouve en tout cas ça ressemble
plus à nos sports à nous je comprends
qu'il y ait des cas
[ __ ] c'est quoi la défense avec les
Blancs bah le truc c'est que quand vous
voulez tout prononcer 6 vous allez
abîmer la structure de pion et vous
allez pouvoir contre-attaquer c'est plus
de la contre-attaque et de l'attaque
un coup voilà pour aller faire une
petite enfilade ou quoi donc là les
blancs ils veulent pas juste défendre
leur roi sont oui ça c'est mal embarqué
ils ont depuis moins il faut que je vais
pour autre chose mais c'est les premiers
à taper zone tour en face de la dame qui
avait allié fou qui regarde sur C6 le
faux 3 bien placé voilà après s'il y en
a raison le temps ils enlèvent le foot
17 damage 4 ça va aller vite aussi donc
c'est c'est c'est parti rock opposées en
fait c'est souvent comme ça c'est une
course là sur BC vous l'état ma 4
mais là parfois tu peux essayer de
repartir avec le roi de l'autre côté
mais ce qui va faire damascisse 3D 7 et
tu essayes de dans les trucs comme ça
parfois et le roi il est pas si facile
que ça
[Musique]
c'est à peu près du même niveau en
réalité après Naka il gagne absolument
tous les tournois sur internet mais bon
il y a pas de raison que Douda soit loin
derrière en réalité
en plus il joue pas mal en rapide
etc c'est pas une cadence où il souffre
donc là attention laisse pas tomber
ok oui
après il peut lui aussi repartir vers le
centre probablement faire ça j'espère
que cette tour Eiffel et faire de
l'air pour le roi bah il peut pas faire
flipper il peut faire d'un B7 mais il va
partir en Détroit et heureux de faire
nul donc Douda est obligé de prendre un
risque après le problème c'est quoi
c'est ok on croit des 7
7 pour couvrir la 7e rangée
et surtout B6
après il a tenté le tout pour le tout
avec les Noirs
rester dans la partie pour B8 pas
évident mais bon faut éviter d'enlever
cette en même temps donc tu laisses dans
ma tête du coup ouais
Théodore il fait tomber ok il reste dans
le match alors pour le moment
il est mal mais il a pas perdu j'aurais
commencé à réfléchir à B4 B5 perso pour
venir frapper sur ces 6 et sur D5 mais
bon qui sait fais toi meilleur coup de
l'ordi enfin
peut-être des idées de tourner 5 et
damassables du coup maintenant
ouais donc
8 c'est quand les demi ce sera vendredi
samedi à la finale dimanche lundi ouais
vas-y il y a pas toujours de pause ça
joue tous les jours
[Musique]
à travailler un truc qui semblait juste
évident comme match se terminer dès la
5ème partie
il a poussé le match jusqu'à jusqu'à la
septième ronde c'est pas mal mais cette
fois-ci va s'incliner
il y aura dame processis parce que la
Toro 6 sera clouée et là il y a le feu 5
qui est attaqué donc il y en a qui
arrive de partout après ça c'était la
bonne décision pour pour Jean-Christophe
une erreur est si vite arrivée
et là maintenant c'est une qualité de
moins et il y a plus du tout de jeu
et Douda lui qui en termine avec ce
tournoi
ça y est c'est terminé
on va aller voir les autres parties
qu'est-ce qui se passe côté
radjaboviri est peut-être en train de se
faire reprendre partie
donc on se doute bien que ça devrait
bien se passer voilà et on va aller
jeter juste un
œil à l'autre partie
[Musique]
à son tour magnifique
on va avoir des armaidons dans tous les
sens
ok oui
c'est beau quand même 6 qualifie
quoi donc belle réaction d'orgueil
une grosse avance matériel quand même
attaque de maths
allez c'est pas encore complètement fait
il a pas récupéré le pion encore
il va pas la gagner
en plus en fait il s'est trouvé
[Musique]
sur ce qu'on a vu
trois tours français 3 tu auras deux
ouais non tu avais que attends non bah
oui de toute façon c'est le Piona qui
restera à la fin au cas où je crois que
c'est juste bizarre en fait comme coup
il vient
et rien
il va rien t'arriver ouais
on s'en fout c'est bizarre comme foot je
m'y attendais pas en fait parce que je
lui dis ok juste là tu Stan en fait je
lancer moins roi bien roi juste bêtement
Robin c'est très bien tu fais rien et
puis
jusque là et tu continues et tu fais
rien alors attends il peut essayer ça
tu es changé toi
[Musique]
vraiment gagnant qui a complètement raté
et qui guérit une autre version de nulle
ou rien à faire pour faire une il l'a
donné quoi c'était archi nul après au vu
de la partie c'est normal mais en
passant par là et comme ça c'est juste
étonnant donc c'est viande qui joue pour
égaliser et qui a quatre que faire
regardez toutes ces pièces à l'attaque
les deux fous braquer vers le radar
c'est toujours le théorème des fous il y
a même pas de pions de moi quoi c'est
juste de l'attaque gratos le cavalier
attaque la dame la tour toutes les
pièces attaquent il y a cinq pièces à
l'attaque c'est énorme
ça va éliminer ce qui est G5 qui était
un peu la seule pièce autour du roi
[Musique]
quelle connerie
mais la barre était très heureux
bon bah écoute trop de gaffes trop de
manque de réalisme énormément de gaffes
faut faire attention
tu rajoutes du monde à l'attaque quoi tu
as pas le choix
il peut la perdre bah ouais ça peut
enfin on va voir ce qui se passe tout le
monde peut perdre en fait tu as de
l'attaque quoi enfin tu sais cours
d'avoir
la même chose
quand même donc c'est quand même plus
sympa
de l'autre diagonale enfin Théo ça va
être sympa les speeds les speed chass
cette année bah ouais ouais
genre demain on dirait tiens un match
speechasse bon c'est un peu plus calme
qui est plus trop de tournoi tu dirais
tiens on va se regarder un petit speech
ici ou là il était sympa le match de
Maxime l'an dernier contre
Fabi
ah oui c'est surprenant
vous êtes absolument dégoûté c'est bien
il fait nul et puis il essaye de gagner
la dernière me souvenirs mais juste pour
savoir au lieu de prendre il avait pas
encore H7
ouais mais après peut-être pas moyen
[Musique]
non mais c'est sûr que c'était mieux
mais bon après
[Musique]
tu as pas réussi à faire grand-chose en
réalité et puis fous des cas tu te fais
contrer un peu OK
[Musique]
la seule chance c'est de passer par
là mais bon
ça sert à rien en fait ça c'est
complètement nul
S
ion
je pensais mais je sais pas c'est de
faire à 5 au tout début
et après on aura peut-être un petit
Armageddon si on a du bol
Fabien l'apothéose le rêve
bon voilà
c'est parti au moins ça part
magnifique c'est ça
c'est ça c'était pas une je sais pas
ouais mais
oui enfin comme c'est une transposition
si je conserve c'est la personne mon
skinzo j'ai pas envie de l'embêter avec
la ragozine tu vois
je sais pas ce que toi tu en penses mais
ça c'est le même genre d'idée
je pense que je vais je vais aller voir
après mais je pense que ça doit jouer
dans une heure à l'Armageddon ici on va
pouvoir suivre Sarine sévian alors
oui c'est complètement mais il a pas
encore fait baisser mais avant c'était
quoi ton ruisses qui viennent pousser le
pionements mais excellent très bien
c'est bien qui joue le tout pour le tout
et c'est parti on va attendre c'est une
ruse ça ruse ici quoi
ça commence à suer encore un pour farine
il commence à venir roder ils veulent H4
G3
une menace d'enfilade donc faut faire
quelque chose et
tu conserveront un peu
faible
puissance active ça
se passe pas comme les Noirs c'est pas
gagné pour autant mais
non tu joues quoi après jouer tous les
jours tous les jours tous les jours
comme je fais ça fait vraiment
progresser à force je le sens le seul
problème c'est que du coup avec les
tournois les machins les vidéos et tout
je suis souvent fatigué donc ça c'est
pas bien non plus on va dire que ça fait
tellement progresser à force de le faire
tous les jours que
le jour où je vais le reposer c'est sûr
que je vais être nettement plus fort
qu'avant et puis non plus j'ai fait la
technique de Baki je mets des chics en
petit
pour je vais plus vite non tu vois mieux
l'échiquier mais bon bah qui a raison
les cases elles sont moins loin
elles sont plus proches
donc tout va bien ok
il va prendre la tour à 8 il est loin
quoi
ça fait deux jours que je le fais c'est
le feu ouais ouais c'est beaucoup mieux
en fait dans cette partie ça va décider
dans un autre les deux joueurs qu'on
sort bientôt moins d'une minute
toujours un avantage pour les noirs
manœuvres et manoeuvre c'est bien après
on verra si la va convertir celle-ci il
a souvent raté dans ce match il est de
nouveau gagnant c'est bien ouais il est
très bien on va voir si convertisseur
c'est pas fait juste très bien tu peux
faire des G5 G4 qui vont partir tu auras
la magnifique
alors pour l'instant il y a dame C5
c'est cool mais parce qu'en fait j'ai
regardé mon cadeau 5 et pas échanger
contre un de ces deux plots quoi
[Musique]
tu peux laisser ces pièces un peu
pourries
peut-être B5
c'est quand même c'est quand même
quelque chose
c'est 4 attention il va la rater c'est
bien tu l'auras écouter ici avant que ce
soit terminé
ce sera l'image du match mais écoute on
sait jamais une mais il faut qu'il faut
cliquer quoi garde ton avantage là tu
retombes
comme ça en fait il doit vouloir prendre
le roi pour lui enlever la croix quoi il
va se dire oui on va
veut changer une tour B8 reviens ouais
allez c'est pas comme ça sur lequel il
faut trop réfléchir ensemble
et puis on verra quoi attends il a
est-ce qu'il aurait pas défendu toutes
les cases là ça rentre pas allé
au revoir
allez
pousse ce pion
je sais pas il a 13 secondes
voilà
[Musique]
bien joué ça a priori il bouffe un truc
vous voir le roi transfertez tout ranger
et puis on verra bien
de toute façon
[Musique]
non mais tu es complètement nul il est
complètement nul mais bouge ton roi
allez
qu'est-ce que tu fous
il a été deviné tout le match mais il a
perdu qu'une fois et il a su s'exerce
occasion donc bah écoute bon réaliste
mais sa qualifie ah mais il joue donc
attends faut que je change attends je
change les cames Fab vas-y change tout
Raja Buffalo
4 c'est pas grave il y a des cinq
d'abord ok ça va aussi on peut toujours
ok le 4 il y a toujours des 5
donc il a pris 13000 et 13 minutes ça me
paraît vraiment beaucoup oui
oui on va pas sortir la différence en
fait c'est juste gros avantage d'avoir
les marches je pense et là on décide et
E4 c'est ça mais bizarre dans le choix
pas j'en sais rien je pense qu'il y
avait
14 30 vraiment non en fait lui il
voulait vraiment les blancs
ok ben écoute pourquoi pas donc la règle
de l'Armageddon on la rappelle pour tout
le monde les blancs doivent gagner
les blancs doivent gagner ils sont
obligés
normalement les Noirs c'est quand même
un gros avantage puisque quand tu joues
en Armageddon normal on dit que 6
minutes contre 5 c'est mieux pour les
noirs
et en plus il y a pas de rajouter en
fait on est l'endroit de penser surtout
avec deux joueurs aussi solides que 12
minutes c'est vraiment beaucoup après
l'avantage d'avoir des blancs c'est que
tu sais ce que tu dois faire
bah non si tu sais faire nul quoi ouais
mais des fois jouer pour nul c'est pas
guérir t'inquiète pas mais là j'ai
l'impression qu'en plus avec les Noirs
il sort enfin tu es très heureux là
tu as une position complètement saine et
tu as juste besoin de nul en fait c'est
comme si c'était normal tu avais un peu
afficher l'ouverture pour une bonne
position
[Musique]
c'est William
donc
ouais très bien le 5 il ouvre le centre
il clique assez vite d'ailleurs guérisse
ou des coussins naturels
c'est une option pas vraiment bon après
tu vas toujours prendre le fouger 3 qui
va revenir j'en sais rien j'adore le
coup de l'ordi cavalier H5 pour G5 et
tout et tu es fou
dans de bonnes conditions et tu trouves
le fouger cette cavalière 5 c'est pas
facile comme coup
c'était
prend les devants Fabien
il est ouais
mais c'est déjà la Turbo merde en fait
pour
pour elle est pas terrible alors là il
se met en C1 pour surprise avoir un
vis-à-vis mais
cavalier prend déjà un an pour commencer
et après peut-être trois H7 et F50 enfin
moi je serai chaud en fait
je crois en fait ouais bon
faut voir reculer voilà et mon avis tu
le manges quand même ce fou
serait dommage de le laisser partir non
après tu pourrais venir en F4 avec le
cavalier mais quand même un fou comme ça
ouvert
ça se prend non de le prendre bon après
il réfléchit peut-être au coup d'après
parce que quand tu prends j'ai trois tu
sais qu'il va faire
dans le sens où si tu le fais pas les
blancs fraîches et quatre même en tout
cas lui il a gardé son foulu
donc je sais pas bizarre comme choix
mais bon ça peut s'entendre c'est pas
c'est pas dégueu pour les Noirs après il
peut se dire son cavalier va venir en F4
et qui sera supérieur au fou hein non
non
en fait j'ai quatre sauf quand même le
jeu et si les blancs font G4 il peut
avoir accès à des cases etc tu as un
mauvais fou G7 non non ça peut ça peut
s'entendre en fait ce qu'il a joué pour
le moment en tout cas c'est une partie
qui se passe plutôt plutôt bien pour
Annie mais après il a aussi des gaffes
dans ce match donc attention
Tour Eiffel tu vois tu peux peut-être un
jour replacer ton fond F1 en défense
ça se passe pas génial mais il va jouer
des coups pour pas perdre
et
passer le temps essayer de décider ça à
la fin
tu vas pas faire une victoire en
dominant son adversaire quoi l'arraché
mais
résister jouer vite et je son avantage
au temps de l'armée donc et ça ça
stratégie de match
un peu de temps et en gros ouais son sac
quand tu joues vraiment à 5 minutes 4 tu
aurais fait ça mais à ce moment-là tu as
2 30 contre une
308 des coups t'en fous tu fais qu'il y
ait faim qui est le 3 tu sais pas trop
ce que tu fais quoi mais ça peut marcher
là avec autant de temps en face j'ai
l'impression que c'est tu dois
construire ta victoire ben tu peux pas
juste gagner en visant la conduite c'est
c'est le problème de cette armage à dos
avec beaucoup de temps c'est que ça
dénature un peu le principe même la
nature même de ouais ça dénature la
nature quoi parce que en fait la raison
du coup un de tes argument principal
avec les Blancs je vais pas flag
ouais c'est pour ça que tu es obligé de
gagner en fait c'est
ça te donne une arme supplémentaire que
là ici tu n'as tu l'as aussi mais tu
l'as évidemment beaucoup moins
un peu bizarre
[Musique]
en face de l'autre tour
éviter de perdre à 5 à un moment quand
il bouge le cavalier ou éviter un B5
ouais mais déjà à 5 en soit c'est
soupçonnant parce que B5 c'était pas
tellement de menace enlever le cahier
d'attaquer le C4 donc tu pouvais faire
ce que tu voulais et là la série de coup
est plutôt favorable au blanc je sais
pas s'ils sont mieux c'est pas le
problème là d'ailleurs on voit la jauge
qui égale mais mais on voit ça
s'améliorer côté blanc tu as ton deux
contraintes tu peux créer un purger
je passe un peu mon tour je défends mon
Punto
et je vois un peu ce que tu fais tu as
pas trop de roi H7 j'ai [ __ ] en F7 bon
je suis là je suis bien quoi
sur je te rends le coup mais à trois
c'est quand même un coup très utile
enfin je suis content de l'avoir
mais il le fait
aussi
et tu prends
j'imagine
fou c'est 5 tu vas peut-être tu peux
et tout d'un coup tu vois tu es là non
je suis là et tu revois avec les
fougères
pourquoi pas il se place un peu par là
de bonne case mais la mauvaise pièce on
dit c'est moche ce coup
c'est un coup quoi mais bon faut juste
je comprends bien il veut sur moi H7 et
puis faire F5
mais mon B6 pourquoi pas hein
ça va être une belle opposition de style
si c'est Aniche qui se qualifie
que pour l'arnaquer bah faudra pas qu'il
se fait trop mal au dos
la pro idéal
c'était pas le coup auquel je pensais
que tu allais passer 30 secondes
en deux coups
en fait
j'aime mieux le donner cette crème mais
bon je sois pleutre mais ouais le choix
de choix de prendre les blancs pas
payant pour le moment
il a vraiment choisi quand tu donnes 14
minutes 30 c'est que tu veux avoir les
blancs
B4 faut prendre F7 tu as pas un roi F8
peut-être
donc en fait il faut prendre des cartes
t'as même pas fou prendre en fait ouais
étonnant étonnant choix de Raja bof
après tu vois il aurait donné 12 buts 30
il aurait quand même eu les blancs
j'aurais dit bon
il a là c'est vraiment le fait d'avoir
donné
ça
là il a pu reste le
problème
non quand même pas ah mais il y a F3
j'ai 3 temps
et oui
qui gagne de belles manières
de fondant en fait il a pris l'avantage
dans l'ouverture il a jamais il n'a pas
lâché il a jamais lâché donc on se
retrouve à demain Fab pour pour les
matchs qui opposent qui oppose qui
opposeront Nakamura
après ouais on peut aller avoir le match
nakasso qui peut qui peut être
intéressant ou qui peut être
complètement pourri enfin c'est je sais
pas comment dire là c'est on sait pas
sur le papier pourquoi pas mais
évidemment ça peut se passer
dans tous les cas ce sera marrant oui
c'est vraiment deux joueurs opposés quoi
complètement en position de style en
perspective on se retrouve quand
d'ailleurs demain 17h ça marche voilà
c'est ça